Captain's log. Stardate, National Donut Day.
We're under attack from a ship made of solid fire.
All weapons simply pass through and
come out the other end.
Like that ball bearing I once mistook for a mint.
Oh.
It's a conundrum, Kif. Pray, fetch my travel
tub. I do my best thinking in the shower.
Yeah. Ba ba ba ba ba ba ba bum ba bum ba bum
bum bum.
Could you at least close the curtain, sir?
Certainly.
Lieutenant Croaker!
You expect me to think without a loofah?
Where's my loofah?
What loofah?
You!
You're the loofah.
Oh, well, will you be quiet?
I'm trying to think.
Aha!
Water!
Fire's mortal enemy.
Lieutenant, fire water.
What the-
Who used up all the water?
Your shower depleted the ship's three year
supply, sir.
Well, no worries. I can end this battle with
two words.
We surrender.
Sign this certificate of defeat so I can show
my mom.
Kif, my desk.
I'll just put the old Zapp Hancock on it. Big
confident dot on the 'I'.
Ooh! Ooh!
Oh, you're juicier than I thought, Kif.
Oo.
Oo oo oo.
I have had it!
I'm through putting up with your... crap! I'm
filing a formal complaint.
It's pronounced compliment.